veamos este problema de razonamiento y
tratemos de resolverlo juntos Pregunta
cuántos palitos serán necesarios para la
figura 50 tenemos la figura un con seis
palitos la figura 2s con 11 la figura 3
con 16 la figura 4 con
21 es decir fíjense que cada figura
tiene Aparentemente lo que sería una
casita más si le podemos llamar una
casita más que el valor
anterior y fíjense también vamos a
borrar estas casitas que cada una de
esas casitas representa 1 2 3 cu cco
palitos
más que el término anterior ya que
tenemos una de las paredes esta que ya
permanecía en el valor anterior es decir
que tenemos Cinco más que el término
anterior lo que tenemos que hacer es
entonces Buscar un patrón inductivo para
que nos permita averiguar Cuántos
palitos va a tener la
casa el diseño
50 muy bien veamos también que cada una
de las
casitas Presenta una unidad
más de un múltiplo de cinco esto es una
curiosidad seis es
5 + 1 11 es 2 * 5 + 1 y así 16 y así 21
siempre tenemos una unidad más de uno de
los múltiplos de 5 en este caso es 10
acá tenemos 15 + 1 acá tenemos 20 + 1
por lo tanto todo indicaría que el la el
diseño número 50 también va a tener un
número múltiplo de 5 más una unidad y
fíjense también esta curiosidad
el notemos que este 5 es igual a 5 por 1
este 10 ig 5 por 2 este 15 es ig 5 por 3
y este 20 es ig 5 por 4 y que cada uno
de los múltiplos o de estas formas de
multiplicar a 5 es la posición en donde
se encuentra el diseño
3 4 4 y a cada uno de estos valores se
les está sumando
1 + 1 + 1 por lo que todo indicaría si
no si me permiten conjeturar que el
término 50 va a ser 5 *
50 + 1 y que el término enésimo sería 5
* n + 1 es decir que podemos averiguar
de esta forma con este término enésimo
término general el término el término o
el diseño o cuántos palitos serán
necesarios para el diseño número 50 acá
tenemos que 5 * 50 es
250 + 1 tenemos
251 entonces a la respuesta de Cuántos
palitos serán necesarios para la figura
50 respondemos
251 y esto lo realizamos sin dudar con
un razonamiento inductivo buscamos el
patrón y encontramos el término enésimo
y general